the reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and it's John Humphrey so today we're
gonna talk about our top 5 favorite
killer movies horror killer movies that
are also available on today's sponsor
shudder so if y'all don't know shudder
is basically the ultimate destination
for streaming horror on the internet
whether you're a casual horror fan or a
horror aficionado there's something for
you on shudder as you guys know horror
is a vast genre and over at shudder
you'll find pretty much any variety of
horror film imaginable including tons of
films you just won't find anywhere else
from killer movies like we'll be
discussing today - psychological
thrillers Creature Features classics
documentaries pretty much anything you
can think of they've also got some
horror shorts on there in some original
series along with curated watch lists if
you're looking for a more personal touch
now usually you can find a free 7-day
trial of shudder on their website
however if you guys hit the special link
in the box below and enter our promo
code reel you get a free month of
shudder that's right 30 days 30 days oh
yeah that's right guy set up our special
link in the description box enter our
code reel and get a month of shutter for
free perfect for Halloween so if you're
looking for something freaky to throw on
your big horror fan or you're just in
the mood because it's that time of year
definitely check out shudder now let's
talk about killers
so last time we were talking about
supernatural movies we thought why not
take it the opposite direction come into
the real world a lady so number five on
this list is Rob Zombie's 31 this film
was kind of flew under the radar just a
little bit it's Rob Zombie's latest
entry into his you know real killer
movie thrity exploitation Judy
exploitation one of those like horror
carnival theme types of films Malcolm
McDowell is in it his hot wife Sheri
moon zombie Zin it to this movie when I
first saw it I didn't really quite like
it but then it was oh this one was like
grew on me over time I was just sort of
thinking about it because it's such an
immediate movie and it's what Rob Zombie
does best in terms of tension loud
characters people freaking out are
really committing to the violence and
the insanity of the situation as well
plus there's a really really cool
performance from Richard brick whether
or not you like this film you will not
deny that Richard Break gives a powerful
performance in this movie as a creepy
psychopathic assassin slash serial
killer get it slash even people who
don't like this movie at all cite doom
heda's is one of the best things Rob
Zombie's ever created in terms of
nowadays we don't get exploitation like
this much you know if that's your flavor
I think it's well done check it out it's
also a shutter exclusive number four on
our list we chose the collector the
collector which is a movie from a few
years back some guy who collects coins
yeah yeah it's really scary
I dig his collection this is basically a
cool twist on a home invasion thriller
meets a torture movie it stars this guy
named Josh Stewart who is a really great
actor and who really brings a lot to the
core of this movie it's written and
directed by the team behind saws 4
through 7 the guys who wrote those wrote
it and then Marcus Dunstan directed it
it was designed as a saw prequel
initially and it became its own thing
and it's basically about this thief who
breaks into a house to rob these people
so that he can square off some debts
like and man yeah exactly like ant-man
upon entering the house he discovers
that somebody else has already broken in
and is torturing the family who lives
there yeah you know people he knows so
what starts off as a thief the man must
now become a hero of sorts but will he
succeed and if you're not a big saw fan
but you're still into something
along those lines definitely check out
the collector because the collector
brings a wholly different directing
style with yeah pretty terrific in my
opinion one of those like
under-the-radar again you know indie
horror movies that came up that I really
enjoyed and you guys might do alright so
number three on this list is a movie
that came out in 1977 something of a
classic something of a classic a cult
classic if you will The Hills Have Eyes
directed by Wes Craven now I'm sure most
of you guys would probably at least seen
the remake of the hills I've eyes which
is also pretty good but the original
Hills Have Eyes continues that thing
that you we didn't see Wes Craven do in
his later years it's like this pulpy
gritty really has that like cult touch
to it with the grainy filmmaking kind of
keeps idealism 70s exploitation it came
out a few years after like the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre it's really well done
it's very disturbing it really goes all
out man you know like Old West Craven
versus young Last House on the Left Wes
Craven is very different it's one of
those films that's so maniacal and
disturbing but you respect it because of
how well it's committed to it this is
sort of taken from a true story or at
least a true legend of an actual you
know clan of incestuous cannibals living
in a cave who would you know prey on
people the Alba family the Alba family
exactly the Sony bean album family the
thing about The Hills Have Eyes is it's
still pretty effective in the way you
know those seventies movies are it's
sticky and kind of desolate and paranoid
and strange and it's definitely not as
fast paced and in your face as the
remake is but it's still really
unsettling and it's still really grungy
and makes you feel icky at the end of
the day and yeah that's really effective
and it's also got some of those classic
West Craven touches a little bit of
humor here and there and you know a
pretty relatable central family and I
think when you go back to when you watch
the remake and then you watch this one
the remake kind of makes it feel like
you're dealing with supernatural
characters the original they feel more
like just real deranged people who are
living in these hills which makes it
more effective before he was yondu
that's right number two on our list is
Henry portrait of serial killer from
1986 serial killer
movies are tricky because there are a
lot of famous serial killers and not a
lot of great movies about them and Henry
isn't a real guy but this is perhaps one
of the best serial killer films I've
ever seen in general but especially for
the 80s when when the 80s was a lot of
he got so many Friday the 13 types of
slasher movies there was a specific type
of genre for when it came to serial
killers or slasher films and then when
this movie like Henry comes out it's a
snuff it just feels like a snuff movie
it's got this really fine line between
grindhouse
and arthouse combined into one I feel
like I said that very elegant and plus I
mean Michael Rooker is ok Gary it's
really about Michael Rooker is is really
terrific in that movie and it's one of
those again he's one of those actors who
sort of has flown under the radar for so
long and he is a gem and that movie is
definitely indicative of that it's hard
to watch it holds up still you know it's
a rough movie because you're kind of
just spending time with Henry it's
called a portrait and it really is like
character self-portrait it's not like
we're completely dissecting the
psychology but in a way we are hanging
out with Henry it's really eerie and
disturbing arguably should be number one
on this list but in terms of rewatch
ability our next one would be a lot more
rewatchable number one on this list is
the film john actually introduced me to
this movie called maniac which i really
did enjoy which is actually a remake I
didn't you know that eighties movie yeah
the original one still has a
first-person element to it and it is you
know the same central idea however the
first one takes place in New York and
it's centers around Joe spinel who's it
just a totally different build and vibe
for this character and the remake
transplants it into LA yeah and goes
with kind of the opposite character
played by Elijah Wood this sort of timid
you know lady frail little guy yes
lonely you get a good understanding of
the psychology of why he turned out the
way he did the man's relationship with
his mom is very important here you
really get to explore that I found the
directing style very fascinating because
I thought this whole first-person point
of view I thought it was a gimmick at
first then you realize that you are
living by
curiously through him which is this
weird alternate transporting experience
when you're watching it because when
he's not killing people you kind of like
the guy he was your identify with him
and you understand if he has these
central feelings of humanity and
loneliness that we can all get on board
for and plus he's got this chick that
he's into that she doesn't know he's a
killer and with it so when she doesn't
know that you kind of hope that he can
get with her in some way i toes an
interesting line of grayness where
you're like ah you know you really
someone needs to stop you however I feel
so bad for you in a weird way and Elijah
Wood even though most of the movie is in
first person he does bring a lot to the
character and in terms of all the
slasher movies I've ever seen or all day
you know serial killer movies I've ever
seen it does do something to bring you
into his mindset and to be more than
just you know ah cool kills in a bad
body count and and it doesn't have to be
as crazy of a psychological study in
terms of a script because there is
something really effective I'm really
happy this movie isn't in VR or I feel
like it would really mess with my mind
has already did mess with my mind the
first time I watched it watching it just
through a television screen really does
transport you into his mind it's that
weird debate of man should I like this
movie but he's like scalping women yes
movie you feel it it's there's never any
violence in this in this specific movie
that you're like that was cool yeah it
definitely makes you feel icky for sure
and there there's some really unsettling
elements that happen he's got this whole
like mannequin farm yeah he's got going
on I don't want to give away too much
about either version well your visit the
other families man come on down and
actually it has that connection to the
hills have eyes in the sense that Alex
aaja is involved with both of these the
remakes yeah he directed the hills I
might as we make he co-wrote and
produced this one it does a similar kind
of thing it updates it for Rana and
piranha 3d and it updates it for the
time and in a really clever and
effective way I thought and before we
hit the road just a couple honorable
mentions a couple other titles I saw
around that I wanted to shout out first
of which is black Christmas not you know
perhaps a Halloween time movie given the
title however black Christmas is a
really terrific proto slasher from 1974
it laid out a lot of the templates for
there's
even before Halloween did yeah if you
haven't seen it definitely worth
checking out John hasn't seen this movie
but Tucker and Dale vs. evil it's kind
of hard to categorize this as a killer
movie even though there's a lot of death
involved in it because you haven't seen
it I don't want to tell you why I'm
saying specifically that and the animals
like we got knock this off the top five
because even though I love love love
this but probably more enthusiastic
about Tucker and Dale vertical than
anything else we talked about you know I
saw the trailer for Tucker Dale and I
kind of get what you're getting at how
this could be a you know a killer movie
that subverts what that means you know
it belongs in the same part of the video
store with an asterisk and yeah next one
I want to shout out was a sleepaway camp
another classic slasher type movie it's
a very strange Philly's movie yeah a lot
of it's very campy and goofy you mean
sleepaway camp yes is campy I walked
into that one it's a very strange movie
with some interesting subplots there's
so much going on and one of the most
shocking twists I've ever seen is that
it's campy you'll never see that - it's
coming just you you just won't
and then also one shoutout pieces pieces
another similar kind of movie very
strange very wacky did you say there are
good pieces in pieces
sure there are some good set pieces in
pieces including a surprise martial arts
attack which you know is great the
tagline for that movie is it's exactly
what you think it is so just you know
watch that we're talking about a lot of
80s movies today yeah yeah there are a
lot of egg killers were very popular in
the eighties and then I also want a
shout out battle royale which you know
people love that battle royale you know
Japanese movie kids killing each other
like the Alba family like the Alba fan a
lot of these movies are autobuyer I have
four brothers that all died by my hand
before I turned 17 Wow
you're the survivor well combline I
assisted my brother took care of most of
the killing I can see you're just the
one who's like cunning and resourceful
go get him well alright those are some
of our favorite killer movies and a
couple honorable mentions and stuff like
that comment below what are some years
what are some
what are some killers you like yeah guys
all these films are available on
shutters streaming service and it is a
fantastic service I heard about this
site brown last Halloween because John's
part of the horror community and I think
once a month for the past year John
doesn't say you know she did she
shuddered the shutter service yeah yeah
I mean if you have a vested interest in
horror at all it seems like the perfect
you want to get especially beyond
mainstream horror into the real like
underground horror but that's also good
shudders a great service for that yeah
if you want some classics some
recognizable titles but you also want to
broaden out check out some things that
maybe you haven't seen or you should
have seen or you've always heard yeah
you know there are plenty of titles like
that lists as well I feel like horror
lately it's been better in the
mainstream but for the longest time it's
it's known to have a lot of cliches and
tropes that make horror predictable and
a lot of the unpredictable more artistic
types of horror films you'll find here
on shutter and that's why we highly
recommend the service all right guys
well thank you for tuning in you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification belt make sure to sign up
for the shudder streaming service use
our special user special code there's a
link in the description box of the
website as well as our special code that
way you get 30 days of shutter for free
I wish we had that offer well now you do
now you do now yondu haha michael rooker
joke was a hooker
oh and he's kind of a looker depending
on your taste in gents yeah yeah Michael
[Music]